Um,
tonight's talk,
this is the most popular talk we've ever
done in 15 years.
Thank you.
Tonight is the third,
so it's been a weekend of Jordan
Peterson,
which has been a huge pleasure for
anyone who doesn't know him.
Um,
and last night I think it was one babe
in arms and tonight it's probably my
mother,
um,
he is a,
was it professor,
associate professor at Harvard
University and is now the professor of
clinical psychology at Toronto.
I'm,
his first book was a huge success.
It revolutionized the psychology of
religion and his latest book of the 12
rules of life is set to do exactly the
same.
I'm just a few housekeeping things.
At the end of the talk we're going to
have a q and a,
which I'm good to moderate.
Um,
so do prepare your questions,
please make them questions and also for
those people in the live stream,
there'll be posted notes and you
couldn't,
uh,
um,
hand questions for the washers and we'll
be taking those as well.
Um,
so,
um,
I look forward to that and at the end of
it we're going to be doing not so much
assigning a bit here onstage,
a dedication.
Um,
everyone's book is,
or pretty well everyone's work is
already signed,
so if you want to,
if you don't want a dedication,
then just leave you.
I'm on the third page.
You'll find the signature.
Um,
in order to last night there was a huge
queue as you can imagine in order to
make the q run smoothly.
And sorry to sound Bossy,
but he's not going to be doing selfies.
I'm a
just because it means he's got to stand
up the whole time and it'll slow down
the flow.
Um,
but he is very happy to be photographed
and you can photo bomb him if you'd
like.
Also because all of us,
particularly me,
I'm a really keen for him to solve the
problems of our lives.
I'm pleased resist doing that,
um,
during the dedication because it'll
really slow everything down.
Um,
I think the three things that you can
take away from this evening,
um,
and you'll be the judges,
first of all,
be inspired by the talk.
Secondly,
read the book and thirdly,
Marissa Canadian,
I feel rather fortunate to have now done
all three.
Um,
also if you would like to tweet about
it,
Hashtag the rules that 12 rules of life.
So without further ado,
please welcome one of the world's great
public intellectuals,
Jordan Peterson.
Well that was nice.
So I thought I'd talk about my book
tonight
given two talks now and I didn't
actually talk directly about it,
I sort of talked around it then.
So I thought I don't like to give the
same talk twice.
So I thought I'd actually walked through
it and,
and,
and outline it a little bit.
And so I had spent most of the day
memorizing the rules.
You know,
you'd think if you worked on something
for three years,
it's been five years,
I guess you'd actually have it
memorized.
But memory is a very strange thing and
it's very particular and goal oriented.
And I actually didn't have the rules
memorized.
It's certainly not their numbers,
so hopefully I do by now,
so I guess we're gonna find out,
but I have a copy of the book here in
case in case I forget,
so I think we'll go through them one by
one and we'll see how,
see how that goes.
Seven o'clock.
So.
Alright,
good.
I'm
the first rule,
which is kind of a comical rule,
is stand up straight with your shoulders
back and it's a meditation among other
things on the habits of lobsters.
I read some papers on lobsters,
boat must be 10 years ago I guess and
they just absolutely blew me away.
And one of the things I've really loved
about being a psychologist and there's
many things,
but I've really loved psychoanalytic
theory and,
and the great clinicians,
the behaviors as well.
I mean Freud,
Jung Adler,
Carl Rogers,
Abraham Maslow,
uh,
that behaviors like skinner and,
and,
and the cognitive behavioral.
I mean I've learned a tremendous amount
from reading the clinicians.
And so if any of you are interested in
psychology,
I would really recommend reading the
Greek clinicians because they know you
learn so much about life.
It's crazy by reading them,
so that's been fun,
but then on the entirely other end of
the spectrum,
where I've learned most about psychology
is from the really low,
what would you call them,
the really science oriented animal
behaviorist,
so that's where they were,
who they turned into the
neuroscientists,
right?
Do they were the animal behaviors first
of all,
and then they turned into the
neuroscientists that I've learned a
tremendous amount from them.
There's such clear thinkers.
The best of the bunch.
I think there's two of them.
One named Jeffrey Gray who wrote a book
called the neuropsychology of anxiety,
which is just a deadly book.
It's impossible to read.
It takes like six months to read it
because I think he he read like 1800 to
write it or something like that and he
actually read them.
That's the cool thing,
and he understood them,
which is really something.
Then there's another guy named Jaak
Panksepp who wrote a book called
affective neuroscience,
which outlines his studies,
for example,
of rats.
He was the guy who learned that rats
laugh if you tickle them with the end of
a pencil eraser,
but they laugh ultrasonically like bats,
so you have to.
You have to slow down the ultrasonic
vocalizations before you can hear them
giggle and you'd think,
why the hell would you spend your time
tickling rats with a pencil and making
them laugh,
but see what he demonstrated there was
that there was a place circuit in
mammals that there's an actual.
There's a psychobiological basis for
rough and tumble play,
for example.
It's a bloody big deal,
you know,
discovering a whole new circuit in the
brain that's like discovering a
continent.
It's Nobel prize winning stuff and
Panksepp's affective neuroscience.
I would highly recommend that.
So there's this other book I know about
too,
which is 12 rules for life,
which you could also look into if you
want.
Anyways,
I was reading these articles on lobsters
and I came across this,
this finding that lobsters,
lobsters governed their postural
flection with Serotonin,
and I thought,
God,
that's so interesting.
It's so into selection is this,
is to stand up straight to Dr. wow,
that's so interesting because you know,
depressed people crouch over.
I wonder if there's any leap between
those two things.
And then I went and read a whole pile of
papers on lobster,
lobster,
neurochemistry,
lobster neurochemistry is actually quite
well understood because they have a
fairly simple nervous system.
Right?
And,
and so if you want to understand the
complex nervous system,
it's a good idea to understand a simple
one first and then sort of elaborate
upwards and it turns out that serotonin
governed status,
a governed status,
emotional regulation and posture in
lobsters just like it does in human
beings.
And so that was just blew me away.
And so one,
one,
one thing that the chapter one is about
is the fact that if a lobster is
defeated in a dominance battle,
you can give it essentially
antidepressants and it will fight again.
Another just blew me away,
you know,
it is.
So,
it's so remarkable because one of the
things that tells you is that,
so if you're a manager,
you could be lobster,
top dog or bottom dog.
Imagine there's 10 strata in the lobster
hierarchy,
so you can be number one,
right,
top lobster,
number 10,
bottom lobster.
If your bottom lobster,
you have low serotonin levels and high
dopamine levels.
That's the neurochemical that human
beings don't produce and if you're a top
last or you have high serotonin levels
and lower top,
I mean levels and you can move a lobster
in its dominance hierarchy by moderating
it's levels of serotonin and I thought
that's so interesting because what it
means is that the counter that keeps
track of our status,
we have a counter in a sense in our
minds that keeps track of our status is
a third of a billion years old
and what that also means is that the
idea of the hierarchy,
let's call it a dominance hierarchy
because within lobsters it's.
It's kind of like a physical prowess
hierarchy,
something like that.
The idea of the hierarchy is at least
350 million years old and so I read that
and I think,
well so much for the idea that human
hierarchies are associate cultural
construct.
It's like,
no,
that's wrong.
It's not just a little bit wrong,
it's unbelievably wrong.
It's mindbogglingly wrong,
right,
and it's
and so,
so hierarchies.
Hierarchies have been around for a third
of a billion years and and we have a
neurochemical system that modulates our,
our understanding of those hierarchies.
And then also,
and this is the interesting thing too,
and this is why people's reputations are
so important to them among there's lots
of reasons,
but this is one of them,
is that
where this counter that you share with
lobsters rates you in terms of your
hierarchical position determines the
ratio of negative emotion to positive
emotion that you feel.
And that's also an absolutely mind
boggling idea for two reasons.
One is it tells you why it's so hard on
people to be put down because it doesn't
just upset them in the moment.
It changes the way their entire system
responds to the world so that they now
experience more positive emotion in less
than a less negative emotion.
So that's really rough.
And then there's a corollary to that
too,
which is like there's a very tight
relationship between your belief system
and your dominance hierarchy position.
It's complicated,
but it's worth going through like let's
say that so I have a certain amount of
status as a professor and and,
and,
and I have the,
let's call it the,
what would you say?
I've been granted the entitlement to a
certain position in a social hierarchy.
Now the question is why do I have a
valid claim to that position and the
answer hypothetically is because I know
enough so that my claim to the position
is valid.
So then if you stand up in the audience
and challenge my beliefs and show that
I'm wrong,
you might.
You might say,
well,
I get upset because I'm wrong,
but the more accurate reason that I get
upset is because you're indicating to
the crowd that my,
my position in the hierarchy of
authority is invalid.
And by doing that you lower me in the
hierarchy and you mess around with the
neurochemical systems that are
regulating my emotions.
And so if you're interested at least in
part in why people are so prone to
defend themselves and their beliefs in
the service of their position,
then that's why.
And so that's a great example of how you
can learn these unbelievable things by
stumbling across a rather obscure
biological fact.
It just,
it just,
what would you say?
It's like a,
it's like a series of dominoes and,
and that's also why biological facts are
so useful.
It's like we don't have to argue about
whether or not social hierarchy says I
said to her are or hierarchies are
social constructs.
A given hierarchy is influenced in its
structure by socio cultural
conditioning,
let's say.
But the fact of the hierarchy.
So the part of your brain that detects
and regulates your response to
hierarchies is older than the part of
your brain that recognizes trees like
it's old.
It's really,
really fundamental.
And so,
and almost all social animals organize
themselves and social in hierarchies
because now the other thing that chapter
one is a bit of a meditation on what
might constitute a hierarchy.
One of my business colleagues and former
student of mine from Harvard,
very,
very smart guy,
it's got a graduate degree in
engineering from Mit and a phd in
psychology from Harvard.
So there's like one of him in the whole
world and he's a very smart guy and he
helped me design the self authoring
suite by the way,
and he's been working for about 20 years
on that.
That's a suite of programs that helps
people write about their lives and
straightened him out.
He told me to stop using the word
dominance hierarchy and he said the
reason for that was that it was infested
with Marxists presuppositions and it
really bothered me when he first said
that because I've been using the word
for years,
dominance hierarchy.
He said we had a discussion about that.
He said,
well,
it's predicated on the idea that you
climb up the hierarchy human hierarchy
as a consequence of the expression of
power.
It's like that's wrong.
You climb up valid hierarchies as a
consequence of the expression of
competence and that's actually
technically right.
He was exactly the right person to tell
me that because he had done his phd on
what predicts success in western
hierarchies.
And the answer is quite clear.
General cognitive ability,
some prefrontal ability as well,
which was what he's specifically tested.
So intelligence.
Roughly speaking,
although it's a little bit more
elaborate than intelligence,
but that's close enough and trait
conscientiousness accounts for about 50
percent of the variance in longterm
success and you think,
well,
hey,
how do you want your society to be
structured?
It seems pretty good to me.
That smart,
hard working people are the ones most
likely to succeed.
That's not a bad empirical test of the
validity of a structure.
You know,
especially given how much vaguery there
is in life.
Lots of random things happen to people,
but it's better to be born three
standard deviations above the mean and
intelligence in the West than it is to
be born.
Three standard deviations above the mean
in wealth in relationship to where
you'll end up when you're 40.
So he said to use the word competence
hierarchy or we decided that and I think
that's much better.
So chapter one is a bit of a meditation
on the nature of hierarchies in the
biochemistry of hierarchy,
but it's also an injunction about how to
present yourself because you don't.
You want to present yourself to the
world in a manner that
that doesn't disgrace you in some sense
that that might be a good way to think
about it and you don't want to disgrace
yourself because the consequences of
disgrace is emotional dysregulation,
more pain,
less positive emotion,
and so the best way to present yourself
is to stand up forthrightly and to
stretch out,
you know,
and to occupy some space and to to to
make yourself sort of vulnerable by
doing that because you open up the front
of your body,
right?
But it's a sign of confidence and that
way people are most likely to give you
the benefit of the doubt and that's a
good way to start regulating your mood.
But not only does it directly regulate
your mood to stand up because it's so
tightly associated,
like pasta reflection is associated with
serotonin and emotional regulation.
But also because if you straighten up
and you present yourself in that manner,
then other people are more likely to
take you seriously.
And that means they'll start treating
you as if you're a number one lobster
instead of a number 10 lobster.
And that's another way that you can at
least give yourself the bloody benefit
of the doubt,
right?
And,
and,
and confront the world in a courageous
manner.
And that's a really good way of also of,
of figuring out how to establish
yourself in multiple competence
hierarchies because one of the general
rules of thumb about how to be
successful is to confront things that
frighten you forthrightly and with
courage.
And that's kind of a universal strategy
for success.
And so that's what the first chapter is
about.
So that's quite fun.
My graduate students,
I told them these lobster stories,
say my graduate students,
when we used to go out for breakfast and
they were a very competitive bunch,
very fractious and witty,
and they were always trying to get one
over on each other,
a making some witty put down or
something like that.
And it got to the point in the
restaurants where they put their claws
in the errands,
click like this when they got one over
on one of their colleagues,
which was very peculiar and strange and
very funny as well.
So,
so that's rule number one.
Rule number two is a treat yourself like
you're someone that you care about and
that's a deeper chapter I would say like
chapter one is kind of comical,
but it's also got this serious
scientific end for example,
and it's practical like most of the
rules are.
Chapter two is a bit of a meditation on
why.
See I read this,
I read this,
this piece of work by young,
the long while back and he was a
meditation on the injunction to treat
your neighbor as you would like to be
treated or something like that and what
you pointed out,
which I really liked was that that
wasn't an injunction to be nice to other
people.
It was an invitation to reciprocity.
It was something like this is like you
should figure out how you would like to
be treated like you were taking care of
yourself,
not how you would like people to respond
to you.
It's more important than that.
It's like,
imagine you had a child that you really
cared for and and someone said,
well,
people will treat this child exactly
like you want them to,
but you have to figure out what that is,
and so then you'd have to sit down for
like a month and you think,
okay,
well how do you want your child to be
treated?
You don't want everyone just to be nice
to him.
You know?
You want people to challenge them and
you want people to discipline them and
we want people to tell him when he's
wrong.
It's like you don't just want everyone
to be nice.
That's,
that's pathetic.
It's pathetic isn't.
There's no challenge in that and so well
you want to treat other people like you
would like to be treated well.
Then you have to figure it out.
How would you like to be treated and why
you'd like people to foreign all over
you and just lay everything at your
feet.
It's like,
no,
that's not something you'd wish for for
someone that you were taken care of,
and then then there's an additional
problem which is it's often the case
that people will treat other people
better than they treat themselves.
That happens extremely frequently.
So one of the things I pointed out,
chapter two was the,
if you have a dog and you take him to a
vet and the vet gives you your
prescription medicine,
you'll go buy the medicine and you will
give it to the dog and you will do it
properly.
But if you go yourself to a doctor and
you get a prescription,
there's one that there's a 30 percent
chance you won't even pick up the
medication.
And if you do,
there's a 50 percent chance that you
won't administer it to yourself
properly.
And so I already thought about when I
first came across that statistic,
it really,
it was another one of those little
facts.
I thought,
what the hell is up with that?
It's like you'll do it for your dog.
So obviously you'll do it for something
you care about and you're conscientious
enough so you'll actually do it.
So like,
why wouldn't you do it for you,
your dog likes you,
you know,
even your dog would rather that you did,
but you don't,
you don't.
And,
and it's actually one of the reasons
that modern medicine doesn't work nearly
as well as it could because people just
don't take their medication and it's not
only because they don't take care of
themselves.
There's some skepticism about doctors,
but you can be just as skeptical about
the vet.
So it's a deep meditation,
I would say,
and it's,
what I've done with these rules is
they're very simple rules and they're
kind of comical and tongue and cheek in
some ways.
But what I've tried to do is like pull
them apart and show what's underneath
the men to go down as deep as I possibly
can.
And in rural too,
it's a bit of a meditation on why people
don't like themselves very much.
And I think there's two reasons really.
One is that we're,
we're fragile and damageable and
imperfect in multiple dimensions all the
time.
And that often just gets worse,
it gets lots of things get worse as you
get old,
for example.
So it's not necessarily that easy for a
self conscious being who's
extraordinarily aware of his or her own
fragility and,
but not just virgility
foolishness and errors.
His like,
you know,
yourself better than anyone else knows
you and you know,
you,
you might have a certain amount of
dislike for someone,
you know,
because of something they did.
But you know,
everything you did,
Jesus,
that's a drag man.
You know,
you have to carry that along behind.
It's like,
really,
I did that,
you know?
And then so there's that.
It's like you're your week and kind of
useless and prone to temptation and you
know,
all those things that just shouldn't be
that way.
And then you're also capable of pretty
vicious acts of malevolence.
And so you also know that about
yourself.
And so it's a real existential question
for people's like,
why the hell should you take care of
something is sorry and wretched as you
are.
And that's really what the chapter's
about.
It's because the answer in the chapter
is,
yeah,
yeah.
You know your first of all,
yes,
you're pretty useless and terrible,
but so is everyone else and that's
actually an existential problem.
Right?
And what I mean that it's a problem that
every human being has always had an
always will,
so it's not just you,
it's a universal problem and that
there's,
there's an answer to that and one of
them is to what is to say love the
sinner,
but hate the sin.
It's something like that is that despite
the fact that you're not all that you
could be,
the proper attitude to have towards
yourself is the attitude that you would
have towards someone that you genuinely
cared for and that it's incumbent on you
to act as if you genuinely care for
yourself just like you would act toward
someone that you actually cared about
some other person.
So it's a reversal in some sense of the
golden rule.
Right?
And,
and it's a discussion of why that's
necessary.
And also more than that,
it's a discussion of why,
why you have a moral obligation to do
that.
It's not just that you should because it
would be better for you.
It's you actually have a moral
obligation to do that.
I think because you make the world a
much better place,
a much worse place if you don't take
care of yourself,
so you should bloody well take care of
yourself,
you know,
because well,
that's what the chapter's about.
It's partly because you have something
valuable to bring into the world.
That's the thing about being an
individual.
It's the thing that Western civilization
has always recognized that as an
individual you have a light that you
have to bring into the world and that if
you don't bring it into the world,
the world is a dimmer place and that's a
bad thing because when the world is a
place,
it can get very,
very,
very dark,
and so it's not just so that you feel
better,
not just so that you're a number one
lobster.
None,
none of those things.
You need to take care of yourself
because you're in the best position to
do that and it's necessary for you to
take care of yourself despite the fact
that we're mortal and vulnerable and
self conscious and capable,
not only capable of doing terrible
things,
but actually do them despite all that
you.
You're still.
You still have that responsibility and
so I wanted to hit the question as hard
as I can to try to figure out well why
people are have are contemptuous of
themselves and there's plenty of reason,
that's for sure,
but the reasons do not justify the
mistreatment of yourself.
It's as simple as that.
It's not a good strategy and the next
rule is make friends with people who
want the best for you,
and that's a meditation on my own
childhood and adolescents to some
degree.
I had friends who wanted the best for me
and friends who didn't know.
They were friends who,
some of them were aiming up and some of
them were aiming down and if you have a
friend that's aiming down and you do
something that's aiming up,
then they're generally not that happy
about it.
You know,
they tried to talk your accomplishment
with one of their own hypothetical or
real or put down what you're doing or
offer you a cigarette if you're trying
to quit and you've kind of done that
successfully or a drink if you've been
drinking too much and are just trying to
stop being an alcoholic,
you know,
or,
or any.
They're cynical and bitter and,
and devoted towards no good.
And sometimes that's family members too
and sometimes it's even part of you,
you know,
but this chapter is a injunction to
people is like,
like you have an ethical responsibility
to take care of yourself.
You have an ethical responsibility to
surround yourself with people who have
the courage and,
and faith and wisdom to wish you well
when you've done something good and to
stop you when you're doing something
destructive.
And if your friends aren't like that,
then they're not your friends.
And maintaining your friendships with
them might not even be in their
interest.
And so it's a tricky argument to make
because I'm not saying,
you know,
whenever anyone's in trouble you should
push them into a ditch and then give
them a couple of kicks.
That's,
that's not the idea.
The idea is that what I had a couple of
rules I didn't write about.
One was be careful,
be careful about whom you share good
news with.
And another was be careful about who you
share bad news with and everyone goes
rules ringing in people's minds quite
quickly.
A friend is someone you can share good
news with.
You know,
you go to them and you say,
hey look,
this good thing happened to me.
And they say,
look,
I'm so happy that that happened to you,
like way to be.
And they don't think,
God dammit,
why didn't that happen to me?
And like,
you know,
you didn't deserve it.
Here's a bunch of reasons you're stupid
and why it won't work.
It's like,
that's not helpful.
And so I would say like if people are,
you know,
the other thing people are doing,
if they're trying to drag you down,
let's say,
is they're trying to see if you'll put
up with it because they have this idea
that maybe life isn't worth living and
things aren't good.
And then if they can be smirch,
let's say,
to use an archaic term,
something that's pristine and good,
then they demonstrate to themselves that
there is no true ideal and that there's
no necessary reason to be responsible
and to strive forward.
And so they use us as a test case.
You know,
I'll just push you down into the low
lobster,
been and see how you respond.
And if you put up with it then yeah,
my cynicism is fully justified.
So.
Well that's chapter three and it's a
painful chapter because it also details
the suicide of one of my friends which
occurred over a very long period of
time.
Not the actual suicide,
but all the pro drama to it.
And so.
And it's sick.
It's a contentious chapter.
Number four is
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday,
not to who's someone else's today,
and the reason I wrote that it was
because I had this client tenure,
I'm clinical psychologist and I've spent
20 hours a week for 25 years listening
to people,
listening to people tell me about their
lives,
you know,
and those people were people who were
just barely hanging onto the bottom of
the world up to people who are so
successful.
You can hardly believe it.
Like the entire gamut of people.
And that's been absolutely fascinating.
It's like,
it's like being a clinical psychologist,
if you really listen,
is like being immersed in a Dostoyevsky
novel all the time,
you know,
because it's amazing what people will
tell you if you listen to them.
They are.
People are so interesting if you
actually listened to them because
they're so peculiar,
like they're like,
penguins are right now services an
ostriches.
They're unlikely creatures.
And anyways,
with regards to,
um,
to a,
comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday,
not as who someone else's today.
I'm this old client of mine,
he was about 85 when he came to.
See me,
and he was a financier and a kind of a
mathematical genius.
He made these little pendants out of a
mathematical symbol for the most
beautiful mathematical equation that was
ever written.
He made them out of gold and he would
hand those out and and he,
he had,
he had studied psychology as a young man
and he introduced me to this concept
that I didn't know about called the
parades distribution,
which see I'd been taught as a
psychologist that most human
characteristics or normally distributed,
right?
So most people were average and some
people were extreme.
Now that's a or normal distribution
intelligence is like that and height.
There's more people of average height
than that.
Very Tall,
very short,
and weight is like that.
And lots of things are normally
distributed and psychologists tend to
assume that everything is,
but it isn't.
Creative products are distributed in a
prieto distribution and that's a whole
different thing and it's really
important to know this.
It's another fundamental fact,
the knowledge of which can sort of
transform the way you conceptualize,
let's say,
the political landscape.
So here,
here's an example of the predo
distribution half.
You know there's a rule of thumb that if
you run a company that 20 percent of
your employees do 80 percent of the work
or the 20 percent of your customers are
responsible for 80 percent of your
sales,
or the 20 percent of them are
responsible for 80 percent of the
customer service calls.
Same thing.
But that's not exactly the rule.
The rule is worse than that.
The rule is
in a given domain,
the square root of the number of people
operating in that domain do half the
productive work.
So you think,
well you have 10 employees,
three of them do half the work.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
what if you have 100 employees?
Then 10 of them do half the work.
What if you have a thousand employees,
then it's 30,
and if it's 10,000 employees then it's
100.
And this actually turns out to be a
rather ironclad rule.
It applies across very,
very many situations.
It applies,
for example,
to the massive stars and the size of
cities.
So you can see how universal it is as a
law and it's,
it's something like those that have
more,
get more and those that have less good,
less,
that's the matthew principle,
right?
To those who have everything more will
be given from those who have nothing.
Everything will be taken away and the
economists sometimes call that the
matthew principle.
And so what that lays out is a world
that's rife with inequality.
So you know,
you hear this idea that I think it's the
85 richest people in the world have more
money than the bottom 2 billion.
That's a pareto distribution phenomena.
And you might say to hell with
capitalism for producing that.
It's like,
sorry,
you got your diagnosis wrong.
It's a natural law.
It's no,
no matter what society you study,
you get a prieto distribution of wealth.
You get a prieto distribution of number
of records recorded.
You'll get a prieto distribution of
number of songs written or goals scored.
Like creative product has that
characteristic.
And it's partly because as you start to
become successful,
let's say people will offer you more and
more opportunities.
And as you start to fail,
people move away from you and you
plummet.
And so,
okay,
so that's rough.
So what it is,
what it means is that there is always a
landscape of inequality and not saying
that we shouldn't do anything about it,
although I am saying that we don't know
what to do about.
That's the thing you know,
because you can modify the prieto
distribution of wealth,
let's say,
but if you,
but we don't know how to do it without
maybe disrupting the system so
completely that it collapses,
which is what happened in the Soviet
Union for example.
And in Mao's China,
they were trying at least in principle
to adjust in equality,
but the cure was far worse than the
disease.
And the,
the truth of the matter is we actually
don't know technically how much
inequality there has to be to generate
wealth.
We can guess.
And you could say,
well,
there should be less than you might say,
well there should be more.
If you're left wing,
you'd say less than if they're.
If you're right wing,
you'd say,
well,
we'll just let the inequality flourish.
But we do know that it's inevitable and
we also know that we don't know how to
regulate it.
So there is inequality.
What that means is there's always gonna
be people around that are better at
something than you are.
And the.
And that's a,
that's a problem because you can get
jealous and you can get bitter and you
can get resentful and worse.
You can get hopeless,
you know,
because you look like,
look,
I have this friend of mine,
he told me something so funny he was,
he was decrying his,
his lack of success in the world.
And he compared himself to his roommate
and he said,
know his roommate,
his college roommate was doing much
better than he was.
And his bloody roommate was Elon Musk.
It's like,
really?
oh,
you're not doing as well as Elon Musk.
I mean,
you can see it would take it rather
personally because they were roommates
and everything.
It wasn't like he was doing badly,
like he wasn't doing pretty damn well.
It's not as good as Elon Musk.
It's like,
yeah,
well you and 7 billion other people,
you know.
But I thought it was instructive
because,
well,
he has.
You have to be careful who you compare
yourself to.
Now you can't just not compare yourself
to others to successful people,
right?
Because then you don't have anything to
emap.
And one of the things I learned from
young,
this was a cool thing.
I'm going to make a real lateral move
here.
Young thought.
The book of revelation was appended to
the Bible because of the Christ in the
Gospels was to merciful.
He was too nice a guy.
Now he's an ideal,
right?
And Young said,
wait a second.
An ideal is always a judge.
That's the thing about an ideal,
because you're not as good as your
ideal.
So your ideal is a judge and revelation
has Christ coming back as a judge.
And that was humans explanation at the
level of the collective unconscious for
the pasting of that remarkably strange
and terrible book onto the end of the,
of the,
of the Bible.
So anyways,
my point is,
is an ideal is if you need an ideal
because you have nothing to aim at,
but an ideal as a judge and you always
fall short of the ideal.
So how the hell can you have the
benefits of having an ideal without
having the crushing blow that goes along
with having the judge that always
regards.
He was insufficient.
So I was trying to work that out in the
chapter and this is something I've had
to work out a lot as a clinical
psychologist.
It's like,
well let's say you need a goal,
but we don't want to let your distance
from the goal crush you.
So you got to set up a goal and then you
gotta make the goal,
break the goal down into parts so that
you can move towards it and you have a
fairly high likelihood of doing it.
So that's a bit a bit of practical.
I wouldn't say advice.
It's because it's better than advice.
It's some practical knowledge about how
to go about achieving an ame.
Set a high aim,
but differentiated down so you know what
the next step is and then make the next
step difficult enough so you have to
push yourself past where you are,
but,
but also provide yourself with a
reasonable probability of success.
It's also what you do with children,
right?
You want to push them because they need
to grow up and be more than they are.
Right?
But you don't want to crush them with
constant failure.
So what you do is aim high and make the
goal approximate difficult but proximal.
So anyways,
so that's one,
one,
one way of looking at it.
But then the next thing is,
you know,
uh,
I've,
I've had clients,
many clients in their thirties who are
trying to.
This is more true with women.
I would say a lot of women who are very
high achieving who established their
career goals at 30 and then want to
differentiate,
differentiate out their life.
They want to have a husband and they
want to have a family.
They're trying to figure out how to do
that.
And one of the things I've noticed that
around 30,
you really have to stop comparing
yourself in some ways to other people.
And the reason for that is that the
particularities of your life are so
idiosyncratic that there isn't anyone
really all that much like you,
you know,
because the details of your life
happened to matter.
And so maybe you compare yourself to
some rockstar or something like that and
you know,
the person's rich and famous and
glamorous and all that,
but you know,
they're alcoholic and they use too much
cocaine and they've had three divorces
and it's like,
how the hell do you make sense out of
that?
Is that someone that you should judge
yourself harshly against,
are not managers is you don't know
because you don't know all the details
of their lives.
And who do you know that you can compare
yourself to?
That's easy you yesterday.
So here's a good goal.
It's something like,
well,
aim high.
And I really mean that.
It's like,
we'll talk about that a little bit to
aim high,
but use as your control yourself.
It's like,
so your goal is to make today some tiny
increment better than yesterday and you
can use better.
You can define better yourself.
This doesn't have to be some imposition
of external morality.
You know,
you know where you're weak and
insufficient,
where you could improve fake,
okay,
well this is what I'm like yesterday.
If I did this little thing,
things would be just an increment better
and well,
that's a great thing because you get the
ball rolling and incremental improvement
is unstoppable.
You can actually implement it and it
starts to generate pareto distribution.
Light consequences.
It starts to compound and I've seen that
happen in people's lives over and all,
and people write me all the time and
tell me that they're doing that,
but I've seen that happen in people's
lives continually.
They make a goal,
a goal that the goal should be.
How could I conceive of my life so that
if I had that life,
it would clearly be worth living so I
wouldn't have to be bitter,
resentful,
deceitful,
arrogant,
and vengeful.
Like that's sort of the bottom line,
right?
Because that's what endless failure does
to you.
It's not good and that's what life
without purpose and a goal does to you
as well because life is very hard,
so you think,
okay,
well I need to adopt a mode of being
that would justify my suffering and you
can ask yourself that question.
What would make this worthwhile need a
quote Nietzsche?
I think in that chapter he said he who
has a why can bear almost.
Anyhow,
that's a lovely lied man.
I mean it's a lovely line and it's
really worth thinking about.
So you think,
well,
how do I manage all this misery and
suffering and futility?
It's like,
well,
I need to figure out what I would have
to do in order to make that clearly
worthwhile,
and so then you have your goal and then
you think,
well,
I need to move towards that
incrementally because I'm kind of
useless and can only do so much and
maybe not even that,
but all I have to do is be a little bit
better than my,
my miserable self yesterday and that'll
propel you forward very rapidly and you
can succeed at it.
Which is also really lovely because why
not set yourself up for success,
you know,
because otherwise you drove around like
a number 10 lobster and you know,
that's just not good.
You get a pinchy when that happens and
it's not a good thing.
So that was,
that was chapter four,
chapter five g's recruiting long here.
Chapter five is the one that I thought I
would get in the most trouble for
writing.
You know,
I figured people would be all over me
for this and so far they haven't been,
but they still might be so in it's
called do not let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them.
And I thought that would be contentious
first of all because people would think,
well I never just like my children.
It's like
really,
really?
You know,
you're going to really tell me that God
when there's a more.
There's a more horrifying element to
that too.
Because as a clinical psychologist I've
seen the full Friday of nightmare.
I can tell you that.
And you know,
I've seen families where it's like,
this is like the family members are
standing in a circle.
Let's say,
and each of them has their hands around
each other's neck and they're squeezing
hard enough to strangle the other person
in 20 years and that's the family.
It's like,
you know,
if you,
if you haven't met a family like that or
well then you're not paying attention
and there is,
there's some reasonable possibility that
you're actually in a family like that.
So the idea that parents can't dislike
their children,
it's like God,
how naive can you get?
It's just,
that's just if you think that man,
you don't even know where you start to
straighten yourself out high could never
disliked my children's.
Yeah.
Well those are the people who produce
the most monstrous children too.
I can tell you that.
So,
so,
and then there's this idea that young
had,
which I really love,
which is the idea of the shadow and you
know it,
it Kinda got pop psychology and trendy
sort of among the new age types too.
But one thing I can tell you about Carl
young is no matter what else someone
might say about him,
he is absolutely not new age.
If you read Carl young and you
understand them and you're not terrified
right to the depths of your soul,
you haven't understood a damn thing
you've read and one of the things that
you said about the shadow,
which is the dark side of humanity,
the dark side of each individual was
that its roots reached all the way to
hell and he meant something.
He meant something very specific,
both metaphysical and practical.
By that the metaphysical element was he
meant hell literally and metaphysically,
but he also meant the more proximal
kinds of hell and so what he meant was
that if you were able to understand your
dark side than you would see in yourself
a reflection of the behavior that was.
That was present at Auschwitz,
for example,
and that the reason that people don't
take the dark side of themselves
seriously at all,
even confront the fact that it exists is
because no one wants to see that
reflected within them and no wonder like
it's absolutely no wonder.
You also believed that that
confrontation with the shadow was an
inevitable barrier to enlightenment.
That there was no.
You know,
Joseph Campbell,
who was a popularizer of young to some
degree,
has become well known for saying follow
your bliss and,
and,
and you know,
Campbell learned virtually everything
you knew from young but young that isn't
what young said at all.
He said,
pursue what's meaningful and you'll
encounter or that which you least want
to encounter.
And that's what.
That's the dragon,
that's the dragon.
The towards gold for example.
And the dragon is also something that
lives inside you and it's not something
that you take the encounter with
lightly.
There are very old stories about this.
There's this story about the God horus
who was Egyptian savior in some sense,
and when he encountered evil,
even though he was a god,
he lost an eye in the battle.
And so that's,
that's the famous Egyptian I,
you know,
that everyone still knows about.
That's the eye of horus that was torn
out by seth who is the precursor to
Satan and so and so.
It's,
it's,
it's no joke.
It's no joke back to children.
See,
I kind of knew this when I had my kids.
I had already undergone that to some
degree and and understood what it meant
to be a bad person,
a terrible person,
and one of the things I knew that was
that that manifested itself in families
all the time.
Tyrannical father over protective
mother,
more rarely over protective mother,
tyrannical,
overprotective,
father,
tyrannical mother.
It's usually the other way around and
the terrible pathological familial drama
that Freud made much of in the early
20th century.
I'd seen that in many,
many situations.
Dismal,
brutal,
awful,
and I've seen parents punish their
children and you can also take a page
from niche if you really want to punish
your children or anyone else,
if you have someone that you're
interested in punishing,
including yourself when you don't know
what ever punish someone,
you really want to punish for doing
something wrong because now it's
actually a bit of a relief to them.
You know,
that's the theme of Dostoyevsky's crime
and punishment.
The murderer gets away with it and it's
a relief to him.
When he gets caught,
it's like,
no,
if you really want to punish somebody,
wait until they do something good,
then you punish them.
Because that'll teach them,
that's the maximize the hurt,
that way you decrease the probability
that they'll ever do anything good
again.
And I'll tell you,
man,
if you want to have a good relationship
with someone,
that's one thing you don't do.
You Open your bloody eyes and if they do
something that you would like them to do
again,
then you tell them how much you
appreciated the fact that that happened
and you hope that it replicates,
you know,
you see that if there's one thing you
can take away from tonight's lecture,
that's,
that's an extraordinarily useful thing
to know.
Watch,
and when people do something that they
should do more of.
Say,
look,
I saw that you did this specific thing.
I saw that it took some effort.
Here's what it meant.
Here's this.
Here's how I observed.
It's like,
keep that up.
And Man,
if you love someone,
you do that to them.
That's,
that's encouragement.
That's such a great thing.
So anyways,
back to children.
So I already knew that I was pretty
decent monster by the time I had kids.
And I thought,
well,
my kid,
my kid's little,
you know,
like a baby or two year olds,
like I'm horrible monster.
And so that there's an uneven power
problem here.
I better not let that child do anything
that really makes me angry.
You know?
And now you're here now.
And then you hear about something
horrible that happens.
When I was in Boston years ago,
I read about a woman who pledged her two
year old daughter's arms into boiling
water.
You think,
well,
how in the world can that happen?
It's like,
well,
you know,
she's probably hung over.
She'd probably just lost her job.
She was probably desperate and six
different ways.
She probably didn't have any decent
disciplinary disciplinary strategies for
children.
She probably didn't have anyone helping
her.
She was bitter and resentful and angry
and the child misbehaved at exactly the
wrong moment.
And like,
you're going to be around your children
a lot and so you might want to have it
so that they don't misbehave at exactly
the wrong moment because all,
all hell can break loose if they can.
And I didn't want that to happen.
So.
And I knew that it was easy for people
to hate their children even though they
mouth the words that they love the bulk
of the time.
I saw very little evidence of that many
situations.
And so one of the things you know,
you have a natural affinity for children
and even more,
maybe a more powerful natural affinity
for your own children.
So that's a good start,
but you don't want to set them up as an
enemy against you.
You don't want to allow them to engage
in the kind of hierarchical challenge
that makes you irritable and resentful.
That's not a good idea.
And if the things they do make you
dislike them,
the probability that they will make
other people dislike them is
extraordinarily high.
And so you can consult your own
irritability and you can say,
look,
kid,
I used to tell my kids this,
you know,
when they were three or four and say,
look,
I'm not a very good mood and I'm likely
to be unreasonable.
So it'd be best if you'd go into your
room and play for a while.
It's like,
I like you,
man,
you're a great kid.
But like,
get the hell out of here for awhile,
you know,
and they were fine with that.
We've trained them already at that point
to be able to go play by themselves in
their room,
you know,
which is something that a kid should be
able to do anyways.
But,
but you need to know what sort of
monster you are,
if you're going to be a good parent.
And if you think,
oh,
I'm not a monster,
it's like,
Oh yes you are.
You're just an unbelievably unconscious
monster and that's actually the worst
time.
So,
and then the other thing about that
chapter is there's an idea in it and
it's an idea that I think is well
supported by the relevant literature,
which is that your fundamental job as a
parent,
especially if a child from zero to four,
is to make that child eminently
desirable socially.
So what?
You're,
you're a successful parent if when your
child is for all sorts of other children
want to play with him or her,
that's really the.
That's like if you want one marker of
whether or not you've been successful,
that's it.
Now some children are a lot harder to
get along with than others and some
children have a harder time playing and
so I'm not saying that every parent who
has a child that isn't popular at four
is is at fault for that.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying the reverse,
which is you can be sure that you've
been successful if your child is not
popular.
Exactly,
but desirable as a playmate and so then
you think,
well,
what have you done for your child?
Well,
you've opened up the entire world of
children to them so because they know
how to play,
which is a very deep knowledge and it
starts to become inculcated probably at
the breast and certainly in the course
of rough and tumble play at about two
years of age.
It's a deep embodied knowledge.
They know how to play like a good well
trained dog knows how to play.
You know,
you meet a new dog and he'd go like this
and the dog goes like this.
You Think,
oh,
that dog,
I can go like this and it will bite me.
Right?
It knows how to play and it's a kid
who's awake and alert is just like that.
Like a well socialized kit.
If you know anything about kids,
if you can take a four year old and make
a little play gesture at them and
they'll smile right away and start
playing just right now and that's what
you want for your kids and then
everywhere they go,
other kids like them and we'll include
them in their play and play is the way
that children develop.
And so if other children include them in
their play,
then the children develop and the poor
kids that don't get befriended at the
age of four with the literature on.
This is crystal clear.
If your child is an outcast at the age
of four,
the probability that anything can be
done about that is almost zero.
No matter what you do.
And I hate to be so blunt about that,
but I've.
I know the literature and that's what
the literature suggests and so.
And then the other thing is if,
if you don't allow your children to
engage in dislikable behavior than
adults will like them because adults
actually like kids.
You know,
one of the things I loved about having
little kids in Montreal,
I lived in a poor area in Montreal.
There's a lot of rough guys around there
and we used to roll our daughter around
in a stroller and these rough guys,
you know,
like God only knows what they were up to
there.
Rough looking guys.
And you know,
we rolled our daughter by him and
they'd,
they'd like smile and they crouched down
and make a little goofy faces.
And they were.
I tell you,
one of the great things about having
little kids is they bring out the best
in other people.
You see a whole side of humanity.
Even among the darker parts of humanity.
You see a whole side of them that you
wouldn't normally see.
And it's lovely.
And the thing is,
if you're good to your kid in the real
way,
you can help them maintain that
tremendous attractiveness that they have
as young children and to respond to
adults properly.
Like a puppy that wags its tail instead
of growls and you know,
goes for your ankle,
and then wherever they go,
adults welcomed them and teach them
things and pat them on the head and
smile at them genuinely instead of
saying,
oh my God,
here comes to couple with that Goddamn
Brat again.
You know,
which is the horrible.
That's horrible thing to do to a child
because then everywhere they go,
all the good,
all the goodwill is false.
There's nothing that you can do to
someone that's more terrible than to put
them in a world where all the good will
direct it towards them is false.
That's a terrible thing.
So anyways,
that's what chapter.
It's chapter five and chapter six is
about.
It's a rough chapter.
It's about,
I spend a lot of time reading about
totalitarianism and about atrocity,
some brutal,
many,
many brutal things.
Brutal beyond the capacity of
imagination even.
And I read a lot about individual
criminals and serial killers and those
sorts of people trying to get to the
bottom row one book.
I would really recommend this book by
Carl Parents,
Ram,
which is a,
an autobiography,
a ram is the name of the book,
and he was a,
here's a rough guy,
man,
his whatever his dying words to his
executioner,
to his hangman.
He said,
hurry up you who's your bastard?
I could kill 10 men in the time that it
takes you to hang me.
That was his dying words,
you know,
he said,
I wished the human race had one neck so
that I could put my hands around it and
squeeze.
That was Carl Pans,
Ram and not many people like that write
autobiographies.
But he did and he told you why he was
like that and why he thought that way in
case you want to find out,
which I would recommend by the way,
because it's very useful to know such
things.
But um.
Alright.
I have to remember why I told you that
story.
Oh yeah.
Chapter six is about that.
It's about,
it's about pans,
Ram,
and it's about the columbine kids,
the kids who shot up the high school
because I read their diaries and,
and I understood them to,
which is even better than just reading
them and you know,
you see these mass shootings all time
and everyone does the same thing.
Oh,
how did that happen?
Why did that happen?
How can it be this way?
It's like,
well,
why don't you read what they say about
why they did and just assume that that's
the reason.
If you go,
if you go,
oh,
the columbine kids,
oh yeah.
It was like,
oh,
they must've been.
Oh yes.
Because you know,
the natural response of anyone who's
been bullied is to go arm yourself to
the teeth to plot the destruction of the
entire city.
I think it was Detroit to line your
entire high school ave with bombs and
then to go and shoot your classmates.
That's what happens when you're bullied.
It's like,
no,
that's not what happens when you're
bullied as a stupid explanation.
It's shallow beyond belief and it,
and it really emerges only because
people don't want to contend with the
real issue and the columbine kids,
while they were contending with the real
issue,
you know,
they basically said quite forthrightly
that in their own arrogant estimation
being itself was corrupted,
unnecessary,
and it would be best if it was
eradicated in the most brutal possible
way,
as fast as possible.
And you get to places like that.
If you dwell on revenge for three or
four years in your mom's basement,
you know,
you can go to very dark places.
And so that's what chapter six is about.
And you know,
pans,
Ram,
who was very brutally treated when he
was a kid and the column by guys who,
you know,
had their ups and downs,
but nothing compared to Carl Patty,
Patty's Ramsay were,
were judges of being and decided that it
was flawed and that they were the ones
to set it right.
And so it's a rough chapter,
but it's more than that.
It's a meditation on resentment because
resentment is a key human motivation.
And I would say it's,
um,
it's a great teacher to,
to listen to your resentment is one of
the best things you can possibly do.
You have to admit that it exists first
and then you have to admit to the
fantasies that it's generating and you
have to admit to what you would regard
as the way out of it.
So that's all very difficult because it
means learning things about yourself
that you probably don't want to learn,
but resentment only means one of two
things.
It means either like shut the hell up,
grow up,
quit whining,
and get on with it.
That's one thing it means,
or someone is playing the tyrant to you,
might even be you.
And you have something to say and do
that you should say and do to put it to
a stop.
And so maybe and resentment can show you
the pathway to doing that.
Um,
it's a meditation on resentment.
And one of the,
one of the principles that I extracted
from that is like a resentful person
wants other people to change.
And if you're resentful,
then your motivations are trustworthy.
In fact,
they're very,
very dark and that's why I went to the
extreme with people like pens,
Rehmann,
the columbine killers.
I'm resentful.
People who want to change the world are
not to be trusted.
What should you do instead?
How do you treat your own resentment?
I would say,
well,
there's a.
there's a great.
I read this great
line in the Tsl,
eot play called the cocktail party and
in it this woman comes up to a
psychiatrist,
I think this is in this chapter,
and she says,
no,
I'm having a really rough time of it.
I'm suffering badly.
My life is not going well.
And,
and then she says,
I hope that there's something wrong with
me.
And the psychiatrist says,
what the Hell do you mean by that?
And she says,
well,
here's how I look at it.
There's either something wrong with the
world and I'm just in it and that's how
it is.
And then like,
what am I going to do about that?
Because it's the whole world.
Or maybe I could be fortunate and
there's something wrong with me that's
causing all this unnecessary suffering
and if I could just set it right,
I could learn and I can set it right.
And so while I've been thinking about
that for a very long time,
and I think,
well,
if your life isn't going the way it is,
you know,
you can find someone else to blame,
which is pretty convenient for you and
also relatively easy or you could think,
okay,
I don't like life.
I don't like the way my life is
unfolding.
Maybe I don't like life in general
because it's tragic and tainted with
evil.
How do I know if my judgment is
accurate?
And the question is what have I really
done?
Everything I possibly could to set my
life straight because maybe I shouldn't
be judging it's quality or the quality
of life itself or being itself for that
matter.
If I haven't done everything I possibly
could to set my life straight.
Well.
So there's a task,
Solzhenitsyn who I'm a great,
I'm a great admirer of social hits and
his book,
the Gulag Archipelago.
It was one of the things that brought
down the Soviet Union and he said that
one man who stopped lying could bring
down a tyranny and you know,
he said that with some authority that I
can,
I think you could easily make the case
that the Gulag archipelago is the
greatest book of the 20th century.
I mean,
there's other contenders obviously,
but he said when he was in the Gulag
camps,
you know,
meditating on how the hell he got there.
And he had a rough life man.
I mean,
first of all,
he was on the Russian front at the
beginning of world war two and then he
was thrown in the gulag camps and that
was just the beginning of his adventures
man.
He had a rough life and he was in the
camps.
He was thinking,
what the hell?
Like how,
what,
how did I get here?
What's going on?
And he had Hitler and Stalin to blame.
Right?
So if you have,
if you need someone to blame man,
Hitler and Stalin that,
that's great.
But he,
he,
that isn't what he did.
He said he meditated for awhile.
Once he realized that he might have
something to do with in some strange way
with the way things turned out for him
and he said he went over his life with a
fine tooth comb in his memory and
thought,
okay,
where did I go wrong?
But by my own judgment,
when,
when I,
when there was a path in front of me,
when did I take the path that I knew I
shouldn't take?
Because you all know that,
right?
You know,
sometimes you don't know if what you're
doing is good or,
or if it's bad,
it's just ignorance.
You just don't know.
But sometimes you have bloody well know
and you do the thing you know you
shouldn't do anyways.
That happens a lot.
And why do you do that?
Spiked is part of it stupidity.
There's all sorts of reasons,
but you certainly know you do it.
So as units and thought,
okay,
well what would happen if I took
responsibility for where I am in this
concentration camp?
And then I went over my whole life and
tried to figure out all the things I did
that were wrong.
By my own estimation,
that increase the probability that I
would get here and then what would
happen if I tried to set them all right
now in the present and that's why he
wrote the Gulag archipelago and one of
the consequences of that,
as I said,
was it sped the dissolution of the
Soviet Empire.
So hey,
that's not bad.
A like you make a real confession.
You really repent you,
you do your penance,
which is writing this book and you
completely changed the Geo political
landscape of the world.
It's like,
and that that's worth thinking about
because it's not only Solzhenitsyn who
did that,
Nelson Mandela did something quite
similar.
It's not so impossible.
And so the idea that what you should do
if you're feeling resentful about the
nature of being,
are suffering too much for your own
life,
let's say is straightened the damn thing
out.
Like seriously,
try it for a year.
Even try it for a week.
Try Not doing the things you know you
shouldn't do.
Try Not saying the things you know to be
false and just watch what happens.
You might as well give it a shot,
right,
because you say,
well,
I'm all in for a year,
you know,
I'm going to do things right,
and then I'll just stand back and watch
how things unfold and maybe I'll
reconsider at the end of that year.
It's like,
try it,
try it.
I mean,
I would say I've had thousands of
letters now from people who are saying,
Hey,
I tried that,
you know,
and her worked.
No,
I quit lying and everything quit.
You ever seen that simpsons episode
where sideshow Bob keeps stepping on the
rake over and over whole yard is
littered with rakes and all he does is
walk around and step and then curse
steps on a rake and hits him in the face
and he curse isn't any steps on another
rake and it,
you know what I mean?
Stop doing that.
No.
Yeah.
I don't know if we'll get through all 12
rules.
Guess you'll have to read the damn book.
Anyways.
Rule seven,
rule seven just about killed me.
Like I,
I've had a lot of bad health in the last
year and having to rewrite rules,
seven coincided with one of those
periods that lasted about a month and it
was was the hardest chapter by far and
it went down the deepest by far and it
was really hard to get right.
It's called do what is meaningful,
what is expedient,
and I'll just tell you a little bit
about the chapter because I figured
something out in it that hadn't been
explained it.
Something that took me decades to figure
out.
So there's this idea.
It's a very deep Christian idea that the
Messiah is the person who takes the
world sins upon himself,
right?
That's a characteristic of Christ,
Is it's something.
The idea is something like Christ died
for your sins.
It's like what the,
what the hell does that mean?
Exactly.
You know,
and partly what it means,
and I would say a slightly corrupted
form of Christianity,
is that you just have to believe that
that happened in the end,
you're redeemed.
It's like,
well that's.
We'll leave that aside for a second,
but there's an idea there,
a psychological idea and you know that
because it's,
the idea doesn't go away.
It's lasted for thousands of years.
It's like,
well,
so the idea signifies something.
It has a psychological reality,
independent of it's metaphysical
reality,
whatever that might be.
And so I thought about that for a long
time.
It's like,
what in the world does that possibly
mean?
And then I realized,
and you knew this,
Carl Yoga knew this,
that it was associated with this idea of
the shadow.
Um,
I had this client once who,
her parents man,
they were pieces of work.
She,
her parents taught her,
I swear to you that this is the truth.
Her parents taught her that adults were
angels literally.
And when I saw her she was about 30 and
she had a lot of strange symptoms,
symptoms of sorts.
I'd never seen a psychosomatic symptoms.
Um,
she,
uh,
she had kind of like,
cause I epileptic seizures at night and
no,
but she stayed conscious during them.
It was a very difficult to understand it
and I,
I won't walk through it,
but her parents told her that adults
were angels and uh,
and she was like 28,
she had a university degree in and I
said,
well,
didn't you ever
wonder about that?
I said,
didn't you read any history?
And she said,
yeah,
what?
I read something about the terrible
things that people did to each other and
I would just compartmentalize it.
And that was actually the key that I use
to unlock what was wrong with her,
which was eventually fixed.
And I won't go into that.
But,
but I said,
I gave her this book,
give her two books.
I gave her a book called the terror that
comes in the night,
which is a book about,
um,
about sleep paralysis and nightmares
because I thought that was,
what might it be bothering your.
Turned out that wasn't it.
Then I give her this other book called
ordinary ordinary men.
And it's a great book.
That's terrible book,
terrible dark book about,
about this police battalion that was
moved into Poland during World War Two
after the Nazis had marched through and
it was all made of middle aged guys who
weren't like victims of Nazi
totalitarian propaganda when they were
kids.
They were just middle class guys,
kind of like all of us,
let's say.
Um,
and they went to to police Poland and
um,
they were going to have to do some
terrible things essentially,
but their commander told them quite
forthrightly that if being involved in
war time,
policing was too hard on them.
If they felt that it f ethically
violated them are psychological
psychologically violated,
that they could just go back to policing
in Germany.
And very few of them did big.
Partly because they didn't want to
abandon their comrades,
let's say.
They didn't want them to have to do the
dirty work,
you know,
and they ended up,
they were normal policeman.
They ended up the sorts of people who
could take naked pregnant women out into
the middle of the field and shoot them
in the back of the head.
That's how the book.
That's the culmination of their
training.
It's very interesting to read about
their training because they were
absolutely sickened by what they learned
to do,
like physically sick and vomiting,
shaking traumatized,
but they didn't stop and if you want to
know why,
then you can read the book and I said,
look,
read this book,
but don't bloody well compartmentalize
it and enough of that it's like read it
like you're one of the dam policeman,
which is how you should read history,
right?
You read about Nazi Germany and you
think,
well I'm Oskar Schindler.
I had saved the Jews.
It's like,
no you wouldn't.
You wouldn't because people didn't and
the probability is very high that you
wouldn't and all you have to do is think
it through.
You know,
and frank.
It's like you're really going to put
your family at risk to hide a group of
another family in your attic for like
multiple years while there's Nazis
parading the street and where if you get
exposed you will die.
You're going to do that.
Are you like very unlikely and no
wonder.
It's not surprising that it's unlikely,
but you don't want to be inflating
yourself with self,
with fictional heroism,
without actually knowing the facts on
the ground.
So I told her to read,
read it,
and to understand that
the policemen were her and that's the
thing to understand.
Well,
the idea that the savior is the person
who takes the world's sins upon himself
is exactly that.
It's exactly the same idea.
It's like the way that their stops being
Nazis is for you to know that the Nazis
were you and for you to decide not to do
that again,
but you have to know.
You see,
this is the thing that people won't do.
You have to understand that you could
not only do what the Nazi camp guards
did an Auschwitz,
but that you could actually enjoy it
and then you have to decide that you're
not going to do that anymore.
And that's not an easy thing to figure
out.
Well then that's what that chapter is
about.
So that's a rough chapter,
man.
That's a rough chapter and that's the
only,
a bit of what it's about.
You know,
there's a lot of,
there's a lot in there and that's.
Anyways,
that's what.
That's about.
Chapter 10.
It's chapter nine.
Let's see.
Better.
Look,
I'm getting a little tired here.
Oh yes.
Chapter nine is I assume that the person
you are listening to who might know
something you don't.
This is a chapter about conversation and
about the different forms.
Conversation takes and so chapter about
humility and it's a chapter book.
Listening and humility is it took me a
long time to understand why there's
religious injunctions supporting
humility and understand what the word
really meant and that sort of technical
sense and it means something like this.
It means what you don't know is more
important than what you know and that's
a lovely thing to then then what you
don't know can start to be your friend
who see.
People are very defensive about what
they know and for the reasons we've
already discussed,
but the thing is you don't know enough
and you can tell you don't know enough
because your life is not what it could
be and neither is the life of the people
around you.
You just don't know enough,
and so what that means is that every
time you encounter some evidence that
you're ignorant,
someone points it out.
You should be happy about that because
you think,
oh,
you just told me how I'm wrong.
It's like great,
like maybe I had to sift through a lot
of nonsense to get through the real
message that you're telling me,
but if you could actually tell me some
way that I'm wrong and then maybe give
me a hint about how to not be wrong like
that,
well then I wouldn't have to be wrong
like that anymore.
That that would be a good thing and and
you can,
you can.
You can embark on that adventure by
listening to people and if you listen to
people,
they will tell you.
They'll tell you amazing things if you
listen to them and many of those things
are little tools that you can put in
your toolkit like Batman and then you
can go out into the world and use those
tools and you don't have to fall blindly
into a pit quite as often.
And so the humility element as well.
Do you want to be right or do you want
to be learning and it's deeper than
that.
It's do you want to be that the
tyrannical king who's already got
everything figured out or do you want to
be the continually transforming hero or
fuel for that matter?
Who's getting better all the time and
that's actually a choice.
It's a deep choice and it's better to be
the self transforming fool who's humble
enough to make friends with what he or
she doesn't know and to listen when
people talk and listening is a
transformative exercise,
like if if you listen to the people in
your life,
for example,
if you actually listen to them,
they'll tell you what's wrong with them
and how to fix it and what they want.
They can't even help it if you start
listening because people are so shocked
if you actually listen to them that they
tell you all those sorts of things that
they might not have even intended to,
things they don't even know,
and then you can.
You can work with that and so and the
other thing that's so interesting,
you know now and then you have a
meaningful conversation,
right?
You have a good conversation with
somebody.
You walk when you think,
Geez,
you know,
we really connected and I know more than
I did when I came away from that
conversation and during the
conversation,
you're really engrossed in it and that,
that,
that feeling of being engrossed is a
feeling of meaning and the feeling of
meaning is engendered because you're
having a transformative conversation.
Your brain produces that feeling of
meaning for it says,
Oh yeah,
that is exactly where you should be
right here.
Now it's,
it's the right place and time for you
and that's a great place to occupy,
and so a good conversation where people
are listening has exactly that nature
and the reason it has that nature is
because it is in fact transformative.
It's one of the truisms of clinical
psychology,
like if you're a clinical psychologist,
a huge part of what you do is just
listen to people.
It's like they come in,
they're unhappy,
and they'd rather not be something like
that.
You say,
well,
why do you think you might be unhappy
and they don't know.
They have some ideas,
but they may have to ramble around for
like a year before they figure out why
they're unhappy.
They get rid of a bunch of reasons why
they thought they were unhappy that are
untrue,
and then you kind of get to the heart of
the problem and then you might ask them
all if you could have what you wanted so
that your life would be okay,
what would that look like?
Then they have to ramble around a bunch
about that because they don't really
know,
but the listening will straighten them
out because people think by talking and
in order to think,
you have to have someone to listen
because it's very hard to think.
Hardly anyone can think and even the
people who can think can only think
about a limited number of things,
but almost everybody can talk and you
can listen to yourself talk and if
someone listens to you then well then
you also have a foil for your thoughts.
Right?
Because you can watch the person when
you're talking and see if you're boring
or see if you're amusing or if you're
engrossing all of those things.
And so listening.
That's a very good thing.
I outline a Carl Rogers dictum.
He was a famous clinical psychologist.
This is another great little tip.
Rogers said,
here's a trick to tell if you're
listening.
So let's say someone lays out their
perspective for you and then what you do
is say,
look,
here's what I think you said.
I think you said this and this and this
and this,
and then this.
Is that right?
Have I got what you're saying?
Right.
And maybe the person says,
God,
you haven't been listening at all and
you know,
then they have to straighten you out.
Or maybe they say,
yeah,
you got it.
And then the nice thing about that is
that you summarize their argument for
them,
which can be very helpful and for you,
but also you don't get to make the
person into a straw man.
So like if you're arguing with your
wife,
let's say,
or your husband,
big parties going to want to win.
That's stupid because if you win,
you get to be top lobster,
but they get to be bottom lobster and if
you want to live with bottom lobster
then more power to you,
but I wouldn't recommend it.
Right?
Because you don't want that.
You want to.
You want to defeat your wife in an
argument.
Oh well great.
Like if she was going to disappear
tomorrow,
no problem.
But like you're going to like live with
defeated,
miserable her for the next week.
That's no good.
So you listen and you think,
okay,
well here's,
here's what what I think you said and
maybe even make it a little stronger and
more elaborated than was the case with
the original audience so that you get
the damn argument right.
And because you don't want to.
When you want to fix the problem,
that's the winning.
And so the summary with listening so
useful for that because the person can
say,
well yeah,
that's what I meant.
It's like,
then,
well then you have to grapple with that.
And Roger said,
well,
people will usually won't because you
know,
if you live with someone
and they tell you the truth about the
situation,
it usually means that there's something
really stupid that you're doing,
you want them to,
but there's something stupid that you're
doing that you know you're doing,
that you actually have to stop and you
know that's difficult and unlikely,
but well if you don't stop,
then you get to have the same damn
problem everyday or every week for the
rest of your life.
So it's probably better to undergo the
misery of stopping it.
Then the misery of continuing it.
But that's the injunction to listen.
Rule 11 is don't bother children when
they're skateboarding and that's a
meditation on the difference between
weakness and goodness.
You see one of the things that's
happened in our society and especially
with regards to our attitude towards
men,
but also our attitude towards the
masculinity and women.
So it's just as toxic for women is that
we seem to have concluded that strong
men are dangerous.
And that's partly because we think
Western culture is a tyrannical
patriarchy.
And the only reason you get to the top
is because you misused power and so all
the men who are at the top of the heart,
all misusing their power and their all
tyrannical and all the guys who have the
ame an ambition to achieve that or just
tyrants in training and that's sort of
the basic attitude that we have towards
our own culture and towards young men
now.
And that's just.
There's everything about that is
pathological and inexcusable and
shameful in first the claim that western
culture.
Thank you.
The idea that western culture is
primarily a patriarchal tyranny is like,
well,
first of all,
it's,
it's historically ignorant beyond belief
because what are you compared to what
exactly how many civilized countries are
there in the world?
Know three dozen.
The rest of them are run by brutal
thugs.
Right?
And it isn't just thugs at the top,
man,
because that isn't how it works in any
country that's corrupt.
The corruption is spread through the
entire country.
So we're not like that.
And that's that mean western culture is
fundamentally honest.
And I can give an example of that
because people don't like that idea.
Bay proved that because here,
here we did.
It did.
It was a very interesting thing because
when Ebay first popped up,
like the cynic would say,
Ebay is not going to work because I
don't know you.
You live in the other side of the
country,
you're going to send me junk and I'm
going to send you a check that bounces.
And that'll be the end of Ebay.
Right?
Right.
That's what a cynic would say.
And then what happened was that brokers
popped up and they said,
well look,
we'll guarantee the exchange rates for a
fee 10 percent,
we'll make sure that you don't send junk
and we'll make sure your check doesn't
bounce.
And what happened was the brokers
couldn't find enough business.
And the reason for that was all the
transactions were honest.
All of them,
you know,
it's like 19.
If you are on Ebay and you have a
reputation of less than 99 percent,
there's actually something wrong with
you.
You know?
Okay,
Ninety eight percent.
But really it's that,
it's that tight.
And so the default position was you're
offering this all by it will make the
exchange fairly,
and what happened was a bunch of capital
that was frozen,
technically speaking,
junk that people had that other people
could need God freed up and he'd be
freed up a tremendous amount of money
for people and it was all a consequence
of default,
honesty.
And we also know that one of the best
predictors of success in Western world
is conscientiousness and conscientious
people are honest and have integrity and
are due to full and do what they say
they'll do.
And that's a really good predictor of
longterm life success,
especially as a manager and
administrator or something like that.
So
well.
So chapter 11 is a discussion about the
assault on the,
on the positive masculine.
And I read it partly as a continuation
of what Nietzsche announced back in the
late 18 hundreds as the death of God.
Right?
Because in western culture,
God was a masculine figure and the idea
that the divine masculine had been
decimated,
which was basically niches.
Pronouncement has filtered all the way
down to masculinity itself.
And I think that's an absolutely
appalling outcome.
It's,
it's,
it's something that could only be
desired by someone who is a true enemy
of humanity.
And so partly chapter 11 is a call to
encouragement.
It's like you want,
and I've been telling young men in
particular,
but young women as well,
so they don't seem to be quite as in
need of the message to adopt
responsibility for their life,
to tell the truth and to understand that
their failure to participate fully in
being leaves a hole that's precisely the
size of their soul in the cultural
landscape.
It's no joke.
We need all the light we can possibly
bring to bear on the situation.
And while,
and I firmly believe that,
and I believe that for all sorts of
reasons and I think they're very deep
reasons.
And that's partly why I would say rules
to life also has,
it's a funny book because it has a very
religious core,
but it's also very heavily grounded in
evolutionary biology.
So,
um,
but that's what chapter 11 is about.
10,
it's about people who are the enemy of
the human spirit.
The people who restrict children's play,
for example,
which is a particularly pathological
thing to do,
there's a movement now to not let
children have best friends.
It's like,
really what the hell man,
that's so.
There are so many things wrong with that
idea that would take an entire nother
lecture just to scrape the surface,
but mostly it's just,
well,
we're not even
start over.
Final rule.
That's called pet a cat when you
encountered one on the street and it's.
It's very.
It's the most personal chapter in the
book.
It's a lot about my daughter and my
daughter was very ill when she was well
when she was a kid,
but what particularly when she was a
teenager,
she had a very terrible time of it.
She had juvenile rheumatoid arthritis
and when she was between the ages of 14
and 16 at first destroyed her hip,
which had to be replaced and then it
destroyed the ankle on her other leg
which had to be replaced and she walked
around for two years on broken legs and
she was taking massive doses of opiates
and could hardly stay awake and like.
And she had this advanced auto immune
disease which produced all sorts of
other symptoms that were just as bad as
the joint degeneration but which are
harder to describe.
And so it was just bloody brutal,
you know,
and as a test of your faith,
there's almost nothing that's more
direct than a serious illness inflicted
upon an innocent child.
Right.
And so the chapter is a meditation on
that and also on,
well what to do in a situation like that
because everyone is going to have a
situation like that in some sense,
you know,
because you'll be faced with illness in
the people that you love and in crisis.
And so it's a,
it's a practical guide to coping with
those sorts of things.
Like in.
One of the things you do when you're
overwhelmed by crisis is you shorten
your timeframe.
You know,
it's like you can't think about next
month,
maybe you can't even bloody well think
about next week or maybe not even
tomorrow.
You know,
because now is just so overwhelming that
that's all there is.
And that's what you do.
You cut your timeframe back until you
can cope with it,
and if it's not the next week that you
see how to get through,
then it's the next day and if it's not
the next day,
then it's the next hour and if it's not
the next hour,
then it's the next minute.
And you know,
people are very,
very,
very tough.
And it turns out that if you face
things,
it turns out that if you face things
that you can put up with a lot more than
you think you can put up within,
you can do it without becoming
corrupted.
And she did recover quite,
quite fully and much as a consequence of
our own machinations because she figured
out what was wrong with her and then
took the necessary steps to fix it,
which is nothing short of a bloody
miracle as far as I'm concerned.
And,
uh,
anyways,
part of the,
the,
the cat bit is I actually started by
talking about our dog who actually died
about a year ago,
but he's still alive in the book.
Um,
I,
you know,
I let people know because dog lovers
love dogs and if you love cats than they
think you don't like dogs and then they
don't like you.
So I also pointed out at the beginning
of the chapter that,
you know,
if you want a pet,
a dog on the street,
that's okay too.
You don't have to get up in arms about
it,
but,
but the idea is that,
you know,
you have to be alert when you're
suffering.
You have to be alert to the beauty in
life.
The unexpected beauty in life.
And I've kind of what I was trying to
get across with the idea of the cap.
There's this cat that lives across the
street from us,
ginger,
Ginger's,
assignees,
Captain Cat's really aren't domesticated
a technically speaking.
They're still wild animals,
but they kind of like people.
God only knows why,
but they do,
you know.
And so ginger will come wandering over
and our dog looks at her but their
friends and she rolls over on his back
and seek use to noser a bit and then she
kind of Mosey over and let you pet her.
If she was feeling like at that day and
you know you have to look for those
little bit of stuff,
little bit of sparkling crystal in the
darkness when things are bad,
you have to look and see where things
are still beautiful and where there's
still something that's sustaining,
you know,
you narrow your timeframe and you be
grateful for what you have and I've can
get you through some very dark times and
maybe even successfully if you're lucky,
but even if unsuccessfully,
that maybe it's only tragic and not
absolute hell,
and you can do that,
you know,
in the worst situation you can make it
only tragic and not held and there's a
big gap between tragedy and hell.
You know,
there's nothing worse at a deathbed than
to see the people.
They're fighting.
The death is bad enough,
but you can take that as terrible as it
is and make it into something that's
absolutely unbearable.
And maybe I think,
and this is sort of what I closed the
book with,
is this idea,
is that if we didn't all attempt to make
terrible things even worse than they
are,
then maybe we could tolerate the
terrible things that we have to put up
with in order to exist and maybe we
could make the world into a better
place,
you know,
and it's what we shouldn't be doing and
what we could be doing because we don't
have anything better to do.
And that's what the book is about.
And
that's the end of 12 rules for life.
Thank you.
But we've overrun joyously and normally
I would have a sort of cup the talk and
dump something so we can have a
questions,
but I really didn't think it was
appropriate.
Um,
this evening.
Stoke was absolutely luminous and
inspiring.
But.
So I'm going to do one question,
one question only and I'm,
and I'm going to leave Jordan to
actually decide what's the question?
Who's going to ask?
So I'm going to take three from the
audience.
Um,
I'm going to read out three that Ivanka
have come from the live stream.
Um,
one from the live stream is how'd you
challenged the identity politics of
today.
The second is a more personal one is
where do you fall short yourself in
these 12 rules and is it a constant
adjustment?
And now let me take three questions from
the audience and I'll leave Jordan to
then decide which is the last question
that he wants to ask.
So first hand there,
first of all,
it's an honor to be as your lecturer
and,
and the question is I wanted to ask like
for example,
some people like,
Stefan Molyneux who interviewed you,
a puts,
I think,
tremendous,
um,
attention to admitting faults of
parents,
uh,
and admitting the harm that was done,
when getting better and working through
adversive childhood experience.
And I wanted to ask you about,
about that and what you think about
that.
And then if you take the young lady just
here,
sorry,
my question is about chapter nine,
about being humble and listening to what
your enemies are saying and criticizing
you.
I'm,
I'm a kind of person who kind of speak,
speak my thoughts.
So I,
I speak them to my friends and see how
they bounced them.
Um,
so,
um,
I noticed that there's always a group of
my friends who always criticize what I'm
saying and not even try to understand
what I'm,
where I'm coming from.
And um,
I've,
I've always wondered how to deal with
that.
I mean,
I want to listen to what they're saying,
but they're not understanding what I'm,
they're not trying to listen to what I'm
saying.
So what would you do in that situation
that
very briefly,
there's a line in the new testament
that's relevant to that.
Do not cast pearls before swine.
And what that means is that if people
are not listening to you,
stop talking to them.
And that's really,
that is the best piece of advice that I
can give you.
And what happens is,
is that if you stopped talking to people
who aren't listening to you and start
watching them,
instead,
they will tell you what they're up to.
But,
so if you have things to say,
you say them,
but you find people that will listen.
Talk to them,
the ones who aren't listening pullback
because you're a Jew,
you're devaluing what you have to say by
offering it to an audience that does
nothing but rejected and that's a good
guideline to life in general.
So pull back.
Yeah,
and our last question is gentlemen over
there with the blue.
Thank you.
Just a broad smile to my face when you
mentioned the work of John Taylor Gatto
and I just wanted to know what you think
their relationship is between the
classic trivium and the Holy Trinity and
if there is,
how has that changed over time?
I'm going to leave you to answer one
question only and then
you're going to be back on stage.
Dedicated?
Yes.
Okay.
I think I'm going to answer where do you
fall short in these 12 rules?
Is it a constant adjustment?
You know,
I wrote these rules.
What you mean why did I write these
rules?
Well,
you know,
and especially when I said,
well,
you should try to improve yourself
instead of trying to set the world
straight or instead of worrying about
what other people are doing wrong,
you might say,
well that's a hell of a thing for
someone to say,
you just wrote a book called 12 rules
for life.
It's like,
you know,
but the thing is is that I wasn't just
writing that.
I was reading that for me as much as for
anyone else and I mean that's,
I really mean that sincerely.
You know,
I had an opportunity to spend somewhere
around five years meditating on how you
should conduct yourself so that your
life is what it could be.
Like I'm in the group of people that I'm
advising you.
You know what I mean?
It's like all of these things are very
difficult to stand up straight to
remember that and to treat yourself like
you're someone worthwhile and to make
friends with people who are good for you
and,
and to tell the truth or at least not to
lie.
I mean,
these are all ideals,
right?
At especially taken as a whole.
They constitute a kind of ideal and you
never,
you never,
you never attained the ideal,
the eye,
and not only that he receives as you
approach it,
right,
because you straighten yourself out and
you think,
well,
I've got it now and you think,
wait a minute,
there's more to go.
There's still more to go,
and then you get that much farther along
the line.
You think,
cool,
yeah,
I thought this was the end of the road.
It's like,
no,
there's plenty of imperfections left to
iron out,
and so it is a constant adjustment and.
But there's something about that that's
also positive because you might say that
it's not so much that there isn't such a
thing as a good person.
It's that our idea of what constitutes
good isn't right because a good person
is someone who's trying to get better
and no matter how good you are,
there's better that you can get,
but the real goodness is in the attempt,
right?
It's in the,
it's in the process to use somewhat of a
cliche,
you know,
there's this and I'll close with this
and it's a good way to close.
You know,
and this is the psychological
observation,
the the central figure of Western
culture is Christ,
and we can look at that psychologically
because Christ is the dying and
resurrected hero,
and what does that mean psychologically?
While it means that
you learned things painfully,
and when you learn something painfully a
part of you has to die.
That's the pain.
You know when a dream is shattered,
for example,
a huge part of you that that constituted
that dream,
maybe even the biological substrate of
that June has to be
stripped away and burned,
and so life is a constant process of
death and rebirth and to participate in
that fully is to allow yourself to be
redeemed by it.
And so the good is that process of death
and rebirth voluntarily undertaken.
It's like you're not as good as you
could be,
so you let that part of you die.
And if someone comes along and says,
you know,
there's some deadwood here,
man,
it needs to be burned off.
You think,
well,
that stuff's still a bit alive.
When that Burns,
it's going to hurt.
It's like,
yeah,
well,
no kidding,
but maybe the thing that emerges in its
place is something better,
and I think this is the secret of human
beings.
This is what we're like,
you know,
unlike any other creature is that we can
let our old cells die and let our new
selves be born and that's what we should
do.
And so where do I fall short in these 12
rules?
Well,
endlessly because.
here's a way of thinking about it until
the entire world is redeemed.
We all fall short and that's probably a
good
place to stop.
Thanks.